the way I actually
conceptualized the items and the
products I was going to have for road
was in the thought of if I was going on
a plane what would be like the necessary
things I would need to have with me and
that was when we first launched it was
just this the cream and the peptide lip
treatment and now we have the glazing
milk but the thought was always what
would I absolutely need to have with me
on a flight and that is these items so
our glazing milk which is our hydrating
Essence our peptide glazing fluid which
is our gel serum and our berry restore
cream just to keep the skin really
really fresh and dewy and glowy and
protected on the plane ride men this is
for you too don't think that my husband
doesn't use all of these as well